supply get a system of in 2000 they
chanted pray and biker tennis lot of
the arena
[Music]
ghetto expenses chicangana signatures jmg
tradition
with another small
or red
I will be their model
why
[Music]
I on a motorcycle
dakar have been that I want to ride
to  condemnation mode
[Music]
wants to be alone totalitarian
therefore enter that school mode
[Music]
well
and once
[Music]
if the moderator [Music] has said it
with caritas
[Music]
we will pay attention to being the same
we will give rubbish to be in the passion
mutually
storero I do not want
this so that I also see nothing at night 7 a
creta
[Music]
a cow is not going to serve to ignore
scoring and not serve maximum
if he spoke nuggets max from outside area
[Applause]
[Music  ]